favoriser un accès plus efficace aux
vaccins pour les pays les plus pauvres
voilà une des missions rappeler à
l'organisation mondiale du commerce par
sa propre chef
alertés par une campagne de vaccination
quasi inexistante dans certains pays
notamment sur le continent africain
la directrice générale de l'om c'est
entend venir en aide aux plus démunis
contre la pandémie de comics 19
elle a d'ailleurs appelé à ce jour je
cite la mise en place d'un plan de
vaccination
il ya deux aspects la question de santé
publique et la question économique sur
la santé publique j'ai expliqué que je
crois que nous pouvons travailler plus
vite pour sauver des vies afin que des
pays n'est pas attendre des années avant
d'avoir accès au vaccin sur l'économie
le commerce a clairement un rôle à jouer
dans la relance il ya en ce moment dans
le monde plus de 60 pays qui vaccinent
alors que les autres ne le font pas
c'est vraiment dans l'intérêt de chaque
pays que tout le monde soit vacciner car
personne n'est en sécurité
tant que tout le monde n'est pas en
sécurité car dans les régions du monde
les plus modestes
la situation demeure alarmante malgré le
lancement par l'onu du mécanisme kovacs
dont les effets ne seront probablement
pas visibles à court terme
au grand dam de l' oms je dois être
franc le monde est au bord d'un échec
moral catastrophique et le prix de cet
échec sera payé par des vis et des
moyens de subsistance et dans les pays
les plus pauvres du monde
lors du forum économique mondial de
davos le 27 janvier dernier le président
sud africain avait fustigé tout
nationalisme dans les stratégies
d'acquisition du vaccin les pays riches
de ce monde ont acheté de très grandes
quantités de vaccins
certains quatre fois plus que ce dont
ils ont besoin
nous leur disons mettez à disposition
les doses excédentaires que vous avez
commandé est mise de côté
il n'y a absolument aucune raison pour
qu'un pays de 40 millions d'habitants
hachette 120 millions de doses
l'organisation des nations unies
s'inquiètent elles aussi du fossé qui
s'est élargie entre riches et pauvres
l'instance a indiqué en décembre que 32
millions de personnes à travers le monde
avait basculé dans la classe de
l'extrême pauvreté en 2000
en raison de la pandémie un bilan appelé
à s'alourdir si la situation sanitaire
ne s'améliore pas rapidement dans de
nombreux pays de l'hémisphère sud